hey how's it going bros my name it to my
favorite game of all time you Dara's
simulator whoa I'm in here now I can
what you see why I say it's my favorite
game because I can change my underwear
I'm going for the striped blends cos the
stripes shows up the curls up there
girls but
so let's go to school so what our plan
for this episode is to make someone fall
off this roof you have amazing side
boobs mako-chan
so does the other girl a real laughing
and having fun we're all having fun
right
so much fun broy so anyway about that
tampon how do I get it out
all right so here a family you can
eavesdrop on people if they don't see
you and I obviously have amazing Sugoi
dis or Chan panties
I mean sneaking skills your usual self
lately bothering make a child oh my god
well it's nothing if you don't talk
about it that's fine ever since my mom
died my dad's been drinking a lot
sometimes when he's drunk he comes into
my room and
[Music]
what's this I can almost see me to
chance panties [ __ ] is gonna pay for
walking near semis presents 4 p.m. where
the [ __ ] is she oh that son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
where is she
there's yes no one can see me
I am their danger alright justice
alright prison I'm doing that if you're
so there this game is so awesome I can't
wait to play more wants to get updated
grocery you enjoyed this video now's a
great time to leave a like and I'll see
you in the next one as always stay off
so gross
[Music]